per digitale il che vuol dire che ho
avuto un'idea ho avuto un'idea è un'idea
che a che fare col web quindi online e
si presume che per questa idea ci sia
bisogno di grandi capitali a fronte di
una remunerazione incredibile tra alcuni
anni e quindi siamo start up anziché
semplici imprenditori vuol dire mi sento
bollettino come un panettiere che deve
aprire la sua bottega non è che ho
inventato chissà cosa ed è proprio da
qui che vorrei parlarvi o non vi parlerò
direttamente nella mia start up vi
parlerò più che altro delle difficoltà
che ho incontrato quali sono state
scelte giuste quali sbagliate
alcune volte andrò conto magari teorie
economiche piuttosto che di marketing
che sono consolidatissima per delle
grandi aziende mentre per una start up e
tutto differente l'idea e io non la
chiamerei l'idea ma direi un'idea nel
senso molti di voi probabilmente avranno
avuto nella loro vita avranno detto
nella loro vita a questa cosa sarebbe da
fare bisognerebbe aprire un'impresa e
quant'altro e poi cosa si fa si va a
vedere se c'è già e come sempre c'è già
facebook non è non l'ha inventato lui
nel senso c'era già qualcosa di simile
ma facebook ha avuto successo
quindi la domanda che dovreste farvi se
la vostra idea è buona e se quindi ha
senso provare a lanciarvi e perché la
fate non come la fate chi la fa perché
la fate se voi ci credete voi riuscirete
probabilmente a farla molto meglio
impegnandosi mettendoci passione lavoro
tutto quello che ne consegue
però se voi credete nella vostra idea se
siete voi stessi i primi promotori primi
utilizzatori di questa idea avete ottime
possibilità di farcela
il come farla ci sono si può assumere la
risorsa ottima per farla il macchinario
migliore e quindi non è lì che si gioca
sulla concorrenza
qui innanzitutto abbiamo abbiamo avuto
un'idea
io sono proprio convenzionale in realtà
l'idea se adesso amantea statistica
della fisica mi sento tanto sono
organizzata questa startup la
organizzato al contrario il primo fatto
dopo analizzato è una cosa un po strana
mi sono lasciato trasportare che è un po
un po il mio motto è questo è un
consiglio che do a tutti lasciatevi
trasportare cioè fantastica teso vostri
bene all'inizio non costa niente
ragionate andate dai vostri amici
presentate ma non presentate il prodotto
presentate l'idea ciò che ci sta dietro
ciò che voi sentite se vedete che i
vostri amici le persone sconosciute
iniziano ad apprezzare la vostra idea
allora iniziata e salve sono un
pochettino più serie a fare gli
analitici a cercare calco di quant'altro
ma adesso adesso ne parleremo
ok abbiamo avuto l'idea ci è piaciuta i
nostri amici ha detto wow bella cosa
fate la veneta va bene ci ci lanciamo
iniziamo a progettare ed ecco qui che
scatta un pochettino di analisi che
tutti dovrebbero fare che cosa so fare
io ok il perché va bene cielo ora che
cosa so fare una startup digitale questa
cosa importante a mio parere dovrebbe
avere al suo interno cosa che ho
imparato a mie spese
lo sviluppo lo sviluppo di inteso come
software come codice questa è una cosa
importantissima noi ne abbiamo fatta
meno perché io sono un economista un
fratello un maestro di sci e l'altro un
fisioterapista quindi col web centro
nessuno centra niente va bene se abbiamo
fatto lo stesso un consiglio che do e
cercate di un partner che abbia a che
fare direttamente con il web internet di
codice quello che macina codice poiché
la start up il primo costo che andrà ad
affrontare sarà un popolo sviluppo e
trovare uno sviluppatore in grado di
fare bene ciò che voi avete nella testa
solo voi e voi non conoscete il web
quindi non conoscete come si programma
quindi le vostre idee sono difficili da
tramutare in qualcosa dice online è
assolutamente necessario avevano
sviluppato vedenti seconda cosa è e
ottimo avere delle ottime conoscenze in
social marketing social marketing
archetti io personalmente ne avevo poche
le avevo molto accademiche scordatevi
tutto ciò che accademico siete una
startup siede piccolissimi nessuno vi
prendo in considerazione se non quei
pochi fan che avete non avete soldi
avete pochissime risorse politi su
pochissime competenze approfondite
approfondite il social marketing perché
è uno strumento che aiutano in start
upper a diffondere iniziare a diffondere
il seme del nostro prodotto e poi un
giorno lo vedranno sempre di persone
potete sfruttare tecnologie tecniche di
marketing più collaudate puntare molto
ok questa un'altra cosa che ho imparato
quindi noi siamo partiti dall'idea
iniziamo a progettare un pochettino più
sul serio noi venduto a trovare uno
sviluppatore esterno quindi pagare
si inizia a fare come dicevo al
contrario si iniziano a fare business
plan business model costi fissi costi
variabili o dimenticate tutto ciò ecco i
molti i contratti ranno per noi è stato
così nel senso dovete farli nel senso
un'idea di che cosa state facendo se un
senso economico farlo è ovvio perché nel
senso se comprate il pane a 10 euro la
vendita 5 difficilmente campate però non
fidatevi troppo non date troppo peso a
queste previsioni perché molto spesso
specialmente come cadesse sul web
l'idea iniziale viene stravolta lungo
l'idea di business iniziale viene
stravolta lungo vostro percorso di
crescita è molto difficile avere dei
dati veritieri sui quali fare dei conti
tasso di conversione cpm cost per click
qualcuno di voi magari riconosce sono
allenatori hanno che fare solo con
determinato target piuttosto tenuto e
noi avevamo fatto business plan do non
eravamo ricchi dopo un anno eravamo
veramente ricchi sono due anni che sono
e non sono assolutamente ricche e quindi
no non no business model andate avanti a
spanne nel senso ok l'idea rende devo
focalizzarmi su questo aspetto del
prodotto quindi indicativamente la
nostra campagna
di marketing la faremo in questo modo
non siate troppo precisi non siate
troppo professore le tecniche che ti
insegnano all'università va bene per la
ferrero non vanno bene uno start up e
adesso andiamo invece su le difficoltà
vero e proprio che abbiamo che abbiamo
affrontato e video principalmente tre
consigli per lanciare la vostra start up
sul web per noi l'importanza una cosa
molto importante era raggiungere una
massa critica nel senso sul web molti
servizi funzionano solo quando tanti lo
usano bene quando voi iniziate usano in
pochi pochissimi nessuno in realtà 0
quindi aveva una persona vede il vostro
servizio e sarebbe bellissimo ma non c'è
niente quindi me ne vado non mi iscrivo
aveva secondo avanti così il vostro
servizio resta sempre inutilizzabile
quindi un'astratta digitale la prima
cosa che fa investe tutto sul web ogni
centesimo che sia in tasca lo si va a
investire sul web o sul marketing
tradizionale in alcuni casi però si
fanno moltissimi errori
i soldi nel marketing si bruciano in
frettissima una rapidità incredibile qui
bisogna spenderli molto molto molto bene
iniziare da qui google conquista il
mondo no mezzo milione prof
questo per me dalla mia esperienza
personale
non c'è nessun altro oltre google non
c'è o non c'è libro non c'è questo non
c'è quest'altro fa tutto lui quindi il
seo per lui che per google il semplice l
glia divorzio nel pubblicità a pagamento
che voi inserite sono tutte per google
permesso un altro nel senso di vostre
scarse risorse iniziali utilizzate le
prime oltretutto non so se avete notato
ultimamente queste pubblicità compaiono
principalmente sopra gli annunci di
ricerca naturale questo fa sì che quando
vuoi partite dalla vostra start up non
siete sicuramente in prima pagina di
google
nella ricerca naturale dovete pagare per
essere là sopra e questo aumentato
notevolmente i costi del primo problema
che noi ha dovuto affrontare quindi la
maggior parte la vostra campagna
marketing sarà orientata su facebook o
dovrebbe al mio consiglio essere secondo
cui anche noi ci ha fatto molti errori
su questo campo abbiamo scelto di essere
presenti su tutti i social network
apriamo google plus p3 linkedin twitter
facebook e pinterest siamo ovunque
risultato da nessuna parte otteniamo
nulla in scarsa interazione ceca col
tempo però abbiamo capito questa
possibilità che fondamentale analizzare
il vostro target definirlo in modo
preciso nel senso che cosa cercate per
far conoscere il nostro business della
vostra idea
cercate dei influencer c'è persone che
ne parlino di voi a grandi media sul
blog quant'altro allora twitter dovete
rivolgervi lì tutte tutte le vostre
risorse tutte le vostre forze che vi
ricordo sono sempre pochi in una startup
vanno su twitter
non sto da più nient'altro il vostro
target sono prevalentemente la massa
comuni giovani avete contenuti a
condividere su facebook la vostra idea
invece si rifà magari a qualcosa di che
suscita l'idea del futuro per prevedere
se pinterest che fantastico avete
necessità di trovare personale
qualificato
dovete rivolgervi ad aziende un b to b
dovete trovare il responsabile marketing
della ferrero non trovate sul sito della
ferrero e allora c'è linkedin
il concetto è non tutti i social network
e non sono assolutamente tutti uguali
dopodiché quando l'avete scelto valutate
molto bene gli strumenti partiamo ad
esempio che quasi tutte le start up
usano facebook
io sono incubato qui a torino sono
insieme a tantissimi altri start up come
e quasi tutti sono su facebook con la
loro pagina
valutate bene strumenti che riforniscono
c'è la fan page c'è il gruppo c'è la
pagina personale ci sono moltissime
possibilità di farsi vedere e anche
queste non sono tutte uguali
se avete bisogno di interazione ad
esempio c'è il gruppo facebook se avete
bisogno veramente di promozione e di
prendere tutte shaun c'è la fan page nel
mio caso specifico scoperto da poco che
sarebbe stato molto meglio aprire un
gruppo anziché una fan page abbiamo
investito tantissimo a fan page
adesso a quasi due anni dalla nascita
dell'idea si sia resi conto che a si
poteva aprire una bella community su un
gruppo e nell'arco di pochissime
settimane abbiamo risultato abbiamo
ottenuto risultati lontane anni luce da
ottenuto su una fan page perché perché i
nostri utenti cercavano all'interazione
con noi cercare un interazione tra noi e
tra di loro e sulla fan page in questo
non c'è perché l'utente che scrive sulla
fan page ad esempio scrive ma il suo
messaggio lo vede solo lui o chi visita
quella fan page mentre sul gruppo quello
che lui pubblica lo vedono tutti
tutti i membri del gruppo tutta la
community infine una cosa che questo mi
piace per come sono fatto io
il bello di provare provare valutare che
cosa succede e cambiare una strada
digitale significa che qualsiasi cosa
voi facciate sul web in termini di
marketing
potete provarla con un piccolo budget di
un consiglio che video non investite mai
un budget molto elevato perché pensate
di aver trovato lo slogan perfetto
l'immagine perfetto per state lo avete
tutti gli strumenti per analizzare per
averla avete tutte le metriche per
vedere che quello che state facendo se
ha senso oppure no se può essere
migliorato oppure no quando leggete le
metriche andate a modificare una piccola
parte del vostro slogan del vostro
messaggio della vostra immagine a
piccoli pezzi
cercate di raggiungere la perfezione del
messaggio un po alla volta perché il
bello del web e che voi avete le
metriche costa poco cambiare le campagne
marketing s'interrompono e se si fanno
ripartire in pochissimi a volte secondi
e comunque sia in pochissimi giorni
quindi andate avanti per tentoni che
quello che abbiamo fatto fin dall'inizio
cioè trovate arriva il feedback dalle
mitiche cambiate di nuovo uno per
valutare la bontà delle vostre campagne
di marketing 2 per individuare i
problemi nella vostra idea uno strumento
fortissimo e analytics c'è chi dice
subito quella che c'è un problema su
questa pagina perché avete un tasso di
rimbalzo incredibile e lì anche lì
potete immediatamente andare a coprire
quella falla quindi utilizzate questi
questi tre strumenti che per noi sono
passiamo alla maggior parte del tempo da
questo oltre che ad inventare quindi
spero che la mia presentazione di sia
piaciuta che sia stata più che altro
utile per darvi un'idea di che cosa vuol
dire essere start up digitali stata per
digitali e quali problemi si potrebbero
potreste trovare di fronte e vi invito
tutti a farlo perché per me che ancora
non futuro è il lavoro più bello del
mondo
grazie